[Music]
their profits went up and smoke after
embracing the moronic woke but now a
number of Super Bowl commercials will
reportedly avoid a woke nonsense in an
effort to sell their product or at the
very least to keep Kid Rock from
shooting
it turns out leftwing hectoring and ads
only further alienated consumers already
impacted by Biden's economy people don't
need to be called oppressors when they
can't afford eggs so instead this year's
brands are expected to lean into humor
and non-controversial celebrities as
opposed to unfunny hectoring lefties
guess it's not your year Kathy
Griffin meanwhile Trump is extending an
olive branch to Bud Light posting on
Truth social quote the budlight ad was a
mistake of epic proportions and for that
a very big price was paid anheiser bush
is a great American brand that perhaps
deserves a second chance and even trans
Republican Caitlyn Jenner joined Trump
in urging rep Republicans to move
forward from their boycott and that
takes
balls but it's a fair question does bud
deserve a second chance look I'm a fan
of second chances I didn't fire my pool
boy the first time he rejected my
advances put that in the clip reel but
as Tyrus pointed out bud didn't just
lose business they also fired 350
employees in the aftermath of the mulany
debacle and there was a worse outcome
come for buds once prized Clydesdale
horses
yeah bad news for the horses but great
for the Post-it notes
business that really happened that did
happen they sent them away all right
Tyrus so on the one hand you're I mean
you're very passionate about bud in the
fact that they they should rehire the
people they fire do that first before
you cut the checks yeah like but here's
the
thing I'm all for second third chances
in some cases mhm if you show a change
in behavior and you own your mhm giving
good young commedians endorsements is
great but that's not what that's not the
problem 350 Americans who showed up to
work every day bust their ass we out of
work that's what two celebrity checks
yeah get those people America we messed
up we're bringing our forces back and
we're going to weather this storm we'll
respect that giving like I said being a
part of UFC and felt that is that is
great but the only way you stand up to
this woke behavior is by changing
behavior and saying we're not accepting
this anymore and we're going to fix the
wrongs a lot of people were cancelled a
lot of people didn't have the resources
to come back so in effect the Dylan
moleni womanface thing canceled 350
hardworking Americans that don't have
the ability to go on social media or TV
talk shows to get their careers back so
fix that budlight and I'll will be the
first one to go out and buy a bug cake
at my house house and I'll have a keg
party split all right I will be the
first
one but how about you invest in those
350 workers then talk about Redemption
but just moving on and throwing money at
people who already have it don't mean to
me personally Kat on the one hand I'm
happy because I get the feeling that
wokeism is dead but on the other hand
what will we talk about yeah this is
like been my bread and butter for 10
years uh if you would have told me that
I'd spend this much time of my adult
life sitting around talking about Bud
Light like as part of my as part of my
job i' been like no way um yeah I I
think that that what you said really is
at the heart of it is that people want
to chill they don't want to sit there
and be told least of all by people who
are presumably doing better than they
are financially that the they need to
feel bad about the way they're living
people want to watch sports and I was
and again I was a football fan for one
week Between the Lions winning and the
Lion's losing and I experienced a lot of
joy in that week yes they don't they
it's supposed to be an escape from
everything else the people just want to
have fun and again I for me i' I've not
boycotted I mean Bud Light I I don't
drink I just don't really have time to
drink so I haven't really been drinking
but I think that it became people didn't
want to be asked questions about why you
drinking that why you drinking that it
became this lightning rod of a thing so
I think they'd have to overcome that in
order for something to happen yeah is
Bud Light what's wrong with you that's
that's what they got that's what they
got to deal with I think there a lot of
lessons were learned Aaron I mean you
the one thing that they did is they
listened to activists and influencers on
social media who don't even buy their
product it was like an illusion or a d
it's they're listening to people with
delusions which created the illusion
yeah they took bad advice from people
who aren't their like Target demographic
here and even if they were trying to
expand to more people you don't have to
spend 7 million doll in 30 seconds to
have people hate your brand you could do
that in one tweet in two seconds and and
destroy your brand they have chosen to
put money behind a message that they
were trying to sell in relation to a
product that didn't match that's what
upset people and it cost jobs it cost
30% of their market share it's going to
take a lot for them to come back and yes
I love the Clyde sales commercials love
a per commercial with a puppy in it you
you got me sold I'm in on these
commercials but that that's not going to
change what happened how they got here
and and the total Market loss that
they've sustained because when you when
like when you play stupid games you win
stupid prizes and that's what happened
with them they didn't listen they were
inauthentic to their brand and when you
do that is when you're going to get in
the most trouble as a brand Jeff are you
uh a little dismayed that bud hadn't
come to you to be their new spok I have
thought about that like Shane Gillis got
a but light deal and I was like good for
him but the second old Jeff gets sober
now alcohol companies are going M
out if there's a nice coffee company
that would like to uh I'm available but
I I think cat nailed it I I've been
beating this drum for a long time that
what I like about sports is that it's
just sports or what I like about
companies is just companies I I I don't
want to hear from millionaire
athletes trying to lecture everyone
about history they didn't go through and
slavery with while they're dripping in
Nike and blood diamonds when they're
like that's the most hypocritical also
the left or right you would have to
agree that no one cares about
corporations pretending to care about
these social issues yeah it's the
grossest thing to get an email that's
like here at Wells Fargo we stand with
the women's March you're like what
you're a bank come down to Taco Bell get
me two tacos for 99 cents to get out of
here no that drives me nuts it's it's
like I know why you're doing this me too
Taco I thought that was a good I just
took him a solid second it took a Biden
right there to get just kind of like
taco me too I still don't get it that
explains the Green Room thing yes all
right we must move on up next Jen zers
think it's fine to stay home drinking
wine if you'll be in the New York area
and would like tickets to see Gutfeld go
to foxnews.com Gutfeld and click on the
link to join our studio audience hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our Hest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else